Or three,
two
spillover. How are you felling what's
going on? See Ya. Good to see you too.
Thank you very much for taking me up on
that flight. I'm gonna tell you what, no,
legitimately you changed the way I
think about La. It's really small,
isn't it?
It's way smaller than you think.
It's a different thing when you fly over
it. You Go, oh, just ain't that big. Yeah,
that's here.
This is what it is.
I remember when I was still getting my
license and I was doing a night flight,
right. Mom, which is insane.
Totally different ballgame.
Well imagine and uh, yeah,
cause when you're on the
ground you're like, wow,
it'd be really easy to see everybody
because you're looking up and all you've
seen as the backdrop of the dark sky.
Right? Right. But when you get up there,
if someone's below you, they disappear
into the city. So that's what, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. So anyways, so we were flying
back and I trained down in Long Beach,
so we were going along the seven
10 and I just see like all these,
these lights and it was like right down
like going up and I go, what's that?
He goes and I've got a pilot
with Toby goes, oh that's the uh,
that's the fireworks from Disneyland.
And I was like,
fucking Disneyland is right there because
in my head it took like two hours to
get there. Hour and a half going
down the five. But it's just like,
cause you don't look at miles.
All you do is look at time when you
were out here because there's so much
traffic. But it's literally like, oh
that's like 40 miles. It's not even,
it's like from Hollywood,
like I would take it,
it can't even be more than 1520 miles
away. Like Anaheim is so fucking close.
But I just, it's just, or like Irvine
Comedy Club, that's all I think of.
It's just fucking way to fuck down there.
And then you get up in a helicopter and
you're like there and like 11 minutes
going like, this is, this
is ridiculous. So, um, yeah,
yeah. That's awesome dude.
It was awesome. Yeah,
it was a Malibu when you landed on a
top of that little hill there with the
picnic table. Dude, that's funny. I sat
it down Nice. That was a little nervous.
So I'm like, all right, don't
fuck this up with Joe here.
Cause he's going to be like, Eh, forget.
Know. It's all right when he was flying,
when he went, when the big part, when
he went to land, he wasn't that good.
But I'm smooth. And then the
apocalypse now. Shit, we're
going through the canyons.
Dot. I thought that was awesome,
man. That was there. Um, I get it.
There was a fun. That's, it's a a,
it's a lot of fun in the, you know,
I fly mostly with an instructor because
they got the kid and everything,
but every once in a while
you got to go up by yourself,
just so you know you can
do it. But, um, I also, um,
I'm actually over to Overdo to do it,
but I always go out and I do like the
auto rotations and he'll just sorta chuck,
I'm flying along. He'll just chop
throttle and like it, it's just,
it's just rolling the Rpms. I mean,
rolling in the engine now, not the Rpm,
the engine down. And then you immediately
have to pick a spot, you know,
when sometimes you know,
the lower you are, you know,
it becomes literally what you,
the first place you look is where you're
putting it. It's really crazy. But, um,
where you would, where you would
put what you're talking about.
You mean crash landing,
that's an autorotation means it'd be
basically if you had some sort of problem.
Yeah, engine failure, whatever.
So like when you're flying
along in the engine's working,
it's drawing into the disc and that's
what creates lift. But when, uh,
when you go into an auto rotation,
um, it's, it's the air rushing.
You're using gravity, bringing the, uh,
the helicopter down, using that air,
like almost like a fan to keep it going.
So, and there's a critical point where
if you let the main rotor go too slow,
that's why the low rpm horn comes on,
which is just a nausea and sound. Uh,
if you let it go too low,
that when it gets to a point
where if it's spinning too slowly,
no matter how fast you drop, you can't
get it going again, fast enough to create.
And you're basically at that point,
you're in something that's in the longer
able to fly your, uh, your instructors,
Skylar,
Skylar pointed out something that I
didn't know that they have to Redo those
things. Like every x amount of miles, they
rebuild every hours. Yeah. Yeah. It's a,
well, they have like, there's all
this maintenance along the way.
They're incredibly maintained because
I'm sure you noticed if you read the
comments, all people talk about is
dying in aviation. It's like, ah,
that's how entertainers die. It's
like, no, it isn't. They overdose.
If you really looked at the
graph there on the ground,
completely safe overdose car accidents,
there's always over those ranking. Yeah.
And Shit like that. And it's just like,
that's mainly how you die.
Like the amount of people that are up
there every day and then nothing happens.
It's, it's, you know, but
there is the, you know, the,
the fly in the ointment is
that there's, there are, uh,
particularly at the private level, there
are knuckleheads out there like this.
People like I think every time I get in
I'm always thinking like, am I going to,
you know, I don't want to die today. So
I, I go over all a whole bunch of shit.
And you know, especially at my want
to fly solo, I have the whole flight,
I have all my options on,
you know,
where I could land, you
know, if I had a problem,
like that's what you're supposed to do.
I look at weather reports,
I do all of that shit.
And what happens is guys get more and
more confident and their preflight is,
they kind of look, oh, it looks pretty
clear. And then they go out there and, uh,
you know this, you know this, there's,
there's people who go up
knowing that they can die.
And then there's other people out there
who just like magnum Pi and they want to
fly by waterfalls and shit. I mean,
those guys have more fun. But, uh,
it's, you know, there's definitely, um,
those are the people that, you know,
you supposed to fly,
there's like two envelopes.
She supposed to fly within the envelope
of what you're flying and then you know,
your skillset so you don't fly in to
shit. This is like, you know, like if the,
if it's too windy or whatever,
I'm just, I'm just, I'm not going,
even if I could handle it, it's like I'm
not going to have fun up there fucking,
you know, riding it
out and just, you know,
let the wind do what it wants to do and
don't fight it and, you know, make sure,
you know, you're not flying to fail.
You do is slow down, you know. Um,
but you know, it's, it's there,
there are elements of that,
but like if you look up there
versus what's going on down below,
when you fly, I always say this,
when you drive on the highway,
like you're flying in formation,
you're in the blue angels with,
with nobody talking to anybody. You
have no idea what anybody's going to do.
People are texting, they're on medication.
They fucking hung over their suicide.
What the fuck they're doing. You know,
and then the end, the top of that,
you've got to look up for
the guy splitting lanes in
the motorcycles and shit.
Um, it's pretty amazing how few accidents
are actually, are they? It is, it is.
And what I fly,
the Robinson's,
they get a bad rap saying they're not
safe because they look at the amount of
crashes that they've had,
but it's be,
it's because it's a
helicopter you can afford.
So it's inherently a low hour
pilot. And if you look at it, it's,
most of the time it's not, it's
not the helicopter, it's the,
it's the person flying it. Um, which
is why you really have to be on it.
Like you, you, you can't. Um,
it's, it's just not something, uh,
uh, uh, I don't know how to explain
it. It's this weird thing where your,
your level of enjoyment is way higher
if you're, if you're riding in it,
you know what I mean? If you're
the person flying the whole time,
you have your life and other people's
lives at hand so that you're not really,
oh look at that. Oh look at that. Oh look
at that yet. Got Most so like, you know,
thinking things of like, you know, when
we were flying through that canyon,
you need that at that. I think in
that shit, I'm looking, you know,
no one where the wires are and where the
road is cause that's all fucking tree.
So it's going to be the road.
So there's those, you know,
when you're kind of going around a bend,
you know,
this certain like altitudes and
stuff just, it's, it's boring,
but it's just stuff that you're, you're
always thinking that, um, you know,
I imagine like when you fight, does
that, you know, I know with a lot of,
it's like instinct and stuff with this,
these things that you just don't do.
You know what I mean?
I don't know anything about fighting,
but it was heard in boxing. You don't
lead with an opera cut. That's just,
it's just fucking things.
You don't think you see a lot of
guys like when they go to take off,
they do this fucking thing.
Like the nose down attitude.
Like I was taught not to do that.
Cause I know they do that because it
looks cool. I don't know why they do it.
I mean you're supposed
to, like, I was taught,
you're supposed to keep it level so that
way if you have a problem, you know,
you, you're already in the right
attitude to just immediately enter,
enter an auto. Like, now, if I'm,
if I'm fucking nose down and
if I'm too far to the ground,
I'm just gonna fucking go right into
the ground. Um, I dunno, but I mean I'm,
I'm still like totally a novice.
I'm, I'm coming up on 200 hours,
so I don't know a lot, but
I'm super, super, super,
super fucking cautious and,
uh,
I make sure I don't go too long
without doing an auto rotations.
I used to hate them and now I
actually really liked them. Um,
it was sorta the way it was explained
to me, I didn't get it until one day.
I just thought about it and then I
got it and I was able to lock into it.
Cause it's, it's the same inputs
if you were going in for a landing,
but they broke it down to like four
steps. Like it was low Rpm, you know,
lower collective, gentle aft cyclic,
you know, uh, look at you trim strings.
You know, [inaudible] was
a trim, trim, airspeed,
Rpms and just fucking doing all of this.
And the reality is, it's just like,
it's the right pedal. Jesus Christ that
forgot that pedal. So it's all the same.
It's all the same input if you were
going in for a landing. So all I do,
anytime I hear the low rpm is I just
do that and then I'm locked into it and
then I'm just watching Martin
and I can just watch my rpms.
And at this point I've flown enough
where I kind of know where I'm interim,
which basically means you're not like
crabbing and you kind of go in straight
and then you can kind of like pick out
your spot and then it becomes fun as
what's cool is you can do like
one 80 autos. You can turn around.
And what I do like about it is when you
come down to the ground as you can bleed
off all of your airspeed, that forward
motion that's going to fucking kill you.
And as long as you don't fuck up and
flare and go back up and then drop like a,
you know,
it's kind of like a hockey stop
was the way it was described to me.
Just level it out and
running should go to drop.
You pull like that and these guys
land, I'm like daisies and stuff. It's,
it's really amazing. I'm not as good as
that, but like I, I will do it where,
you know, worst case scenario, you know,
I might well like I fuck like
get a little bit of a bump. Yeah.
But I'm going to be all right.
So, um, yeah I don't know.
Now there's probably a
bunch of people saying,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about, which admittedly, you know,
I still think there's a lot of
shit I need to learn about standup.
So as long as you go into
things like that, um, you know,
well the fact that you're doing it in
the fact that you learn in a new thing
that's really difficult to learn.
Don't you think that
that's good for your brain?
Now I am a big believer
in constantly learning.
It's why I like you as a person
cause you're constantly like,
you're not the Joe I knew three years
ago in a good way. You're like, you,
you learn all of this. You know, when
I first met you, you weren't hunting.
Uh, you weren't a marsh. That
was thing you would, you a
two dimensional, you will,
which was amazing because
everyone was just a comedian.
He will this taekwondo champion,
a standup guy. And then,
and then since then,
you've added all,
like the guests that you have on in the
fact that you're able to like talk to
them and stuff is because you've
continued to, you know, um,
you know,
it's,
it's the same thing with like a comic
who writes his first hour and then just
sits on it for like eight years and
all of a sudden two presidents goes by.
It's like, why aren't they
laughing anymore? It's like,
cause you're just stuck
in time. So, um, I, I.